my fellow citizens of this great country  allow the United corporation for a shot  America now this is all about freedom  the freedom free to sit on your big fat  ass all day I'm washing of scenery  greatest sporting event known to man  welcome to the death race  ready for one last us  we are moments away from the starting  gun erasers I scored on total time and  combined pedestrian fatalities with  pinpoints printed off double that first  time and a whopping 50 points this year  cutting-edge technology from UTA puts  you the home viewer in the passenger  seat it's stunning virtual reality  because we see what about Frankenstein  I think Frankenstein will be extinct  tomorrow  [Music]  are you ready  hold on laughs laughs yeah hahaha see  how I'm doing it  I say those points get split right down  the middle  what a thing we've done  oh by the way just for the record my  hair  [Music]  you